well disgraced celebrity lawyer Michael
avenatti facing nearly 100 years behind
bars for allegedly attempting to extort
millions from Nike and for a wire and
fraud case out of California here's how
he's feeling about it what I will say is
the way this has been framed is not
accurate it's just not accurate you're
facing if convicted on all of these
charges up to the rest of your life in
prison are you nervous
well of course I'm nervous are you are
you scared are you concerned I mean tell
us I guess as someone who again has a
history of representing people and now
you're on the other side facing some
serious charges I am nervous I'm
concerned I'm scared Wow Jesse quite a
fall from grace for this guy he was what
grace people were talking about him like
he was a serious 2020 contender at one
point he got a lot of airtime this guy
and now he's in this position what do
you make of it I think he's a classic
shakedown artist scam artist shark and
he needed this big whale of Nike the 20
million dollar payout to keep the house
of cards from falling down on him he is
like he's got the character of Jesse
Smollett with the tastes of Paul
Manafort
while he was skirting all these taxes
for 10 years he spent $200,000 at Neiman
Marcus two hundred and seventy thousand
dollars at Porsche dealerships a hundred
thousand dollars a month rent for a
house in Newport Beach
a 40 grand for Ferrari lease payment the
guy was stealing from clients stiffing
his own employees and the IRS has been
going after him for 10 years he's filed
for bankruptcy protection twice and this
whole time us here have said I know this
guy's a phony because you know why we
have street smarts
CNN book smarts we have street smarts we
can we can smell a phony we can smell a
phony from a mile away and everybody
else bought this guy hook line and
sinker and it blew up in their face this
guy's so obnoxious though and so full of
himself I don't even know if he realizes
yet what could potentially happen to him
what do you think it's a shame he wasn't
arrested in Chicago they would get a
week of community service I'm sorry I'm
sorry why
erase it the media still must be held
accountable for this because they're the
ones that gave him the spotlight but you
know who's having a nice tall beer right
now Brett Kavanaugh justice may be slow
but in this case it's taking a correct
course this is a guy so if you have feel
any pangs of sympathy for this
litigating lollipop remember what he
tried to do to Cavanaugh and I think a
lot of Democrats were mad because you
know he'll he tried to do a better job
at the public hanging weight one said
yesterday that the a vanetti allegations
helped Cavanaugh
might have might have it really ask his
daughters that one one yeah that's true
I mean come on yeah I was rude it was
horrible
cereal gang rapists do you think I don't
think that was ever proved in fact the
fact that it came up empty would helped
Cavanaugh because then it seemed like
everybody was piling on every said due
process everybody was but did I tell you
what I am I'm noting that Cavanaugh
apart is something apart from Cavanaugh
which is Trump and stormy Dan is I think
a lot of people are saying this is
payback on avenatti but I don't see it
though I just think avenatti is
interesting to me that he says he's just
an aggressive attorney and I'm an
aggressive attorney he says this is not
extortion of Nike that he was engaged in
threatening them but people do that all
the time in terms of settlements I think
he's got a twisted view of how you are
an aggressive attorney it's gone over
the line and he may not know it he
should be scared because he may be going
to face real jail time I think yesterday
on the show we said with the two
different peers one in LA in this way a
hundred years in jail Wow
well we'll be happy to pay his rent for
him he's in prison for a hundred years I
was going to say that avenatti needs
smollett lawyers wait credential courses
how can he not pay taxes like how do
people not be taxes I'm ready fifty six
million dollars over ten years I don't
get that I'm sorry taxes is wrong
thank you book smarts
[Laughter]